Social Entrepreneurship is an incredibly
exciting movement that was spawned by
Bill Drayton about 30 years ago,
who an incredibly visionary entrepreneur
who had the idea that you could really
do venture capital for the social sector
so you could pick for visionary
entrepreneurs committed to systematic
social change who had ethical fiber,
who were committed to social impact,
who were innovative,
and you could back them,
give them some resources and the global
support system that allowed them to
achieve their goals,
whether it was an environment,
education,
healthcare,
immigration,
multiple different kinds of areas of
social impact.
And then this movement really rocketed
and what allowed it to do so with both
the vision and the power of Ashoka and
it's offshoots like a endeavor and an
acumen and other wonderful organizations
that support social entrepreneurs.
But it was also the massive growth of
the growth of the social sector.
So the,
the nonprofits,
if you look at the numbers,
they're dramatic between 1980 and a
2005.
You basically had the number of
nonprofits in Brazil go from,
I believe it was something like 5,000 to
nearly a million.
Uh,
you had in the U,
s the number of nonprofits go from
around 400,000 to one point 2 million,
so you had this massive burgeoning of
the social sector suddenly became a much
bigger space with much more impact.
And if you think about it historically,
this is interesting because in the 19th
century we had the industrial revolution
in 18th and 19th century at the
beginning of the 20th century and with
the,
and with the world wars,
we had the massive growth of the state,
uh,
so you had the burgeoning of the state,
but the social sector was left behind
and what you've had in the past decades
is a massive growth of that sector,
almost an industrial revolution for that
sector.
Now,
that creates huge opportunities because
you not only have large numbers of
organizations,
but organizations that can work
together,
uh,
and have a division of labor where you
achieve much more.
Now,
what's the next way for social
entrepreneurship?
Well,
I'm particularly excited by things that
go up the next level,
so that help organizations to work
together very effectively.
Whether it's collaborative technology
architectures,
whether it's organizations like Ashoka,
endeavor and acumen that helped organize
that,
help entrepreneurs to find
commonalities,
show cause it,
group collaborations,
whether it's a financing vehicles that
go to the next level that back a whole
lot of different companies and try to
see or organizations and see the
synergies between those and my companies
and organizations.
Language is the other really exciting.
Next stage I think we're going to see a
whole bunch of hybrid entities going
from zero percent returns,
in other words,
straight charity.
And that's appropriate because why
would,
you know if you're trying to end
slavery,
you're not going to try to do it on a
profitable basis.
Uh,
that is a,
a really charitable activity right
through to highly profitable areas like
microinsurance and microcredit where you
can do a and other kinds of social
business like grameen phone,
the mobile phone company that can be,
all of these can be hugely profitable
and yet hugely impactful.
And I went to see a complete range that
goes,
you know,
minus 10 percent plus five percent plus
20 percent plus 60 percent across the
board.
That works.
Now I happened to be most excited myself
about the areas that really bring profit
and purpose together,
and the reason I'm excited about that is
if you can do something that is hugely
socially impactful,
so it's quality and really helps people
with the products you're selling.
And at the same time is highly
profitable.
It's massively scalable,
and I'm frankly obsessed with the idea
that there are 4 billion poor people out
there.
We don't have time to waste,
we have to do things at scale.
So I want to find mechanisms that really
allow for massive rapid scaling that has
a profound impact on the poor.
And that I think is the most exciting,
uh,
arrowhead of social entrepreneurship
right.